[Music]
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know our weekly Bible question and
answer program you know I was just
thinking back when I graduated from
college they they gave all of us who
were theology Majors a a a Bible and uh
I had that Bible for many many years and
and like bibles if you use them enough
the the the covers fell off and the
pages began to get Doge geed and so I I
retired my Bible you I put in a little
plastic bag and I kept it but uh as as
you know ministers tend to move a lot
and in all of that moving I I lost my
first Bible it's it's someplace that I
cannot lay my hands on it uh but I've
got a new Bible which which I love just
as much and you know what has the same
words in it I didn't lose anything it's
it's just it was just sentimental you
know and and and the the writer says Thy
word have hidden my heart and that's
where really the words ought to be so
maybe I'll see my Bible one day again I
don't know maybe so maybe not but I say
that to to to say to you we become very
attached to these swords that we carry
around because we spend so much time in
them and with them and they fortify our
lives I'm in the company of two fellow
Travelers on the road to Glory Pastor
Steven bore the president of this fine
Ministry secet unsealed and some TV and
Pastor David Salazar who superintends
our Latino channel here uh and together
we're here to answer your questions and
to do the very best we can to come from
the word of God each and every time you
send a question is in rather that's the
promise that we make to you should you
like to get in on the fun and we pray
and hope that you do we' ask you to send
your questions to TV at sutv Su
mv.org TVM tv.org and we will get to
your questions just as quickly as we can
you will notice that we don't rush
through the questions that is because
you take the time to write them we think
we ought to take requisite time to
answer them rather than quantity we want
quality answers so that you know
precisely what God wants from you amen
and how you are to respond from the word
of God so Pastor David Salas if you
would ask God's blessing upon this
program absolutely we will begin let us
pray heavenly father as we come before
you once again we are so delighted that
we can receive from your throne of grace
the measure of your holy spirit that it
will come in abundance for us to
understand to hear and to be able to
present your word I pray now that you
will help us to speak your words touch
our lips anoint our minds so that the
words that we may speak may bring peace
people closer to the truth and to the
knowledge of your son Jesus Christ and I
pray all of these in Jesus name amen
amen and amen our first question comes
to us from Bethlehem Pennsylvania that's
fairly near your old stomping grounds
down in Jersey I've been to be myself uh
spending much time in the East this is
from Andre and um uh here's his question
we are taught in the writings of the
spirit of Prophecy that Christ
experienced the second death on behalf
of all Humanity while on the cross of
Calvary and that he knew what it was
like to be eternally separated from the
father with absolutely no hope of being
with God
again this was done out of love for man
so man would not have to to experience
that we're taught that in the humanity
of that the humanity of Jesus died but
the Divinity or the god part did not die
because Divinity can never die can you
explain this with some scriptures
please oh you're looking at
me I had indeed okay um in
2018 I wrote a newsletter article you
know every uh three months I write a
rather lengthy uh newsletter article on
different theological matters m and in
2018 this would be the first quarter of
that year I wrote an article and the
title of the article is Reflections on
second death and I'll show it to you uh
by the way if you download our app uh
this will be a good uh opportunity to
advertise our app if you download our
app you can not only watch all of the
presentations that we've done for
television but you can also read all of
the newsletter articles that I've
written and the study notes as well mhm
and uh so I'll just share very quickly
because I know that my fellow laborers
here uh have some things to say about
this um I did it in a form of a question
and answer a first question is what is
sin MH well obviously 1 John 3:4
transgression of the law MH how many
have sinned all all have sin and come
short of the glory of God what are the
wages of sin death death
now the question is which death the
first death or the second death after
the
Millennium that's a see there's a more
silence
now
both precisely both yeah yeah but
primarily second death second death yeah
I mean yes the wages of sin is second
death because it's contrasted with
eternal life right okay so uh the next
question is um what is second death
that's the important question well the
answer depends on whether you're a
seventh day avenus or whether you're a
Mainline Protestant MH the mainline
Protestants will tell you that second
death is eternally burning in
Hell whereas the Seventh Day Adventist
Church says that there will be suffering
in the fire but the fire will go out so
that's the difference between the
Seventh Adventist Church and the
religious World in general Adventist
believe that yes there will be torment
there will be suffering in the fire but
eventually the fire will go out along
with the person who is Burning uh
whereas Mainline protestantism says that
uh they're going to burn forever in hell
that's second death okay so the next
question is did Jesus suffer second
death did Jesus suffer that death most
of the Christian world says yes he
suffered second death
I beg to
differ Jesus did not suffer second death
Jesus experienced second death Jesus
experienced what second death is like
like true when he was on the cross
because uh you know he felt separated
from his father on the cross he said my
God my God why have you forsaken me he
felt like Sinners will feel when there's
no hope absolutely in other words and so
Jesus did not suffer sick and death he
experienced sick and death you say how
do you know that he didn't suffer sick
and death well he's not burning in hell
is he you think he didn't consume like
that yeah and he's not going and he's
not going to burn temporarily in hell
and suffer the torment in Hell after the
Millennium is he no no no so there has
to be another explanation mhh and only
seventh day adven are able to provide
that
explanation and what is that explanation
has to do with the sanctuary no it's
your
turn two things I want to just
just tap on that you that you you
mentioned because I'm I'm I've looked at
at uh Andre's question he he got it
right he didn't use the word suffer at
all he used the word experience both
times right so so his his theology is is
correct um Ellen White tells us that the
grave that that Christ's eyes did not
open up for him the idea that there was
anything beyond that he he suffered he
really
experience what it is to be separated
from God so in that uh the the
experience was genuine and legitimate
because he he did not know that his his
sacrifice is going to be uh accepted
until he made that short trip to heaven
on Sunday morning um so there was no uh
it was a a legitimate experience of
second death and what was your question
I forgive me I just my brain is
okay um if Jesus suffered second
death according to the Adventist
view he would have to burn after the
Millennium temporarily and then go
out if we go by the Evangelical world he
would have to be in hell now forever
yeahh forever yeah um and neither one of
those are true so the question is who
ultimately will suffer second day
death it has to do with the most holy
place yes on the day of atonement so now
I framed it I'm not going to say anymore
okay okay so so to take that one step
further has to do with the scapegoat
also right it's it's got to be because
that's where ultimately the sin
originated and that's who ultimately has
has to pay that's my being in the pock
now
yours let's see if I get it right no um
I I do think that what Pastor Rory is is
really
going at and I think is is absolutely
right the sanctuary message and the
sanctuary service in the day of
atonement give us the clear picture of
how the issue of receiving the second
death would come upon the originator of
sin itself and so Christ as the lamb
substitute lamb for us he had to
experience the penalty of sin we we
understand that very very clear he had
to experience the consequences of what
that sin does to The Sinner that's why
he received the the the death experience
and he experim or he uh as you mention
but he experimented the death for us he
tasted that for us if you will but he
didn't receive the the actual element of
the the second death in his own life
because that is reserved for the
scapegoat in this in sanctuary services
or to the originator of sin which is
going to be Satan Christ will
transferred on that final day when the
final Millennium is done and then he
condemns Satan to destruction to the
second death he will transferred all the
iniquity all the sins that were placed
on him for Humanity back to Satan so
that he actually re receives all the
condemnation of that sin that was placed
on Christ but uh for for our sakes but
ultimately goes back to Satan who was
the one that originated and the one that
caused the sin in the first place now my
pastor let me TOS a football to you
because um uh we have been accused in
times past by other religious
fraternities of making Satan our sin
Bearer and we know that Christ was our
sin Bearer how does Christ get to
transfer those sins to Satan through the
sanctuary servic so that Christ is our
sin Bearer but Satan actually Satan
ultimately pays for the sins that he
causes the world to follow you follow my
question yeah the bottom line is that
the sins were forgiven when the person
repented and confessed their sins and
trusted in Jesus there you go they were
transferred through the blood of Christ
to the sanctuary there you go the
scapegoat is not sacrificed and without
shedding of blood there is no remission
the word remission means forgiveness and
so the scapegoat is not forgiving sin no
a scapegoat is suffering the final
consequences for the sin that he
originated in the
universe um now the wicked they suffer
their own second death the scapegoat
suffers only for those who place their
sins through the blood of Christ in the
sanctuary that's the key and and so
ultimately uh you know if Christ wants
to um bring Salvation through that
method by transferring the forgiven sins
in the sanctuary to the scapegoat so
that the scapegoat now suffers the final
penalty because he originated sin in the
universe uh more power to him he has the
right to do it only to do it precisely
and you know more and more
Scholars uh are coming to the conclusion
I have a bunch of quotations in this AR
artical are coming to the conclusion
that the scapegoat is a symbol of Satan
so for many many many uh years uh
Scholars would say well you know it's
two different dimensions of Christ you
know two different aspects of Christ but
now Scholars are coming to the
conclusion that the scapegoat really uh
is is um a symbol of Satan and you know
it's interesting that there were two
goats
chosen um on the day of atonement and uh
one was for the Lord Lord's go mhm and
the other was was for aaz now they're no
not they're not both of the Lord because
it says one for the Lord and the other
for AEL in Jewish tradition I have
quotations in here as well in Jewish
tradition um a zazil is an e the evil
spirit that brought sin into the
universe and so the Jews understood that
ail represents that malignant Satan who
brought us into all of this mess who
will ultimately bear the final penalty
and that's the reason why Ellen White is
correct in early writings when she says
that some Sinners will suffer a short
period others will suffer many days and
she says after all of the Sinners have
gone out yeah Satan must live and suffer
much longer imagine if some Sinners
suffer many days for their own sins yes
how much is Saint going to suffer for
all of the sins of the redeemed that
were placed on Jesus Christ it's going
to be much longer than what we generally
assume but even for him it will not be
for eternity it will have an end he will
eventually go out Ezekiel chapter 28
says that he will be reduced to ashes
and he will be no more amen and amen
very good study pastor well done well
done we we saw YouTu because you had the
book yeah we saw you bring the book
in we'll start with the rabbi and then
well I want everybody I want everybody
to get uh this study because all of the
verses and quotations from Ellen White
are in this article and uh so the the
purpose is to get everybody to do their
own research yeah that's one of the
things that I appreciated since coming
to this ministry that God has blessed
you to produce so much written material
which now can be downloaded you know uh
and people can have that you can print
it out if you wish or you can transfer
to your computer but you have this
biblical record this this apologetic
that is very linear very easy to
understand and you can refer to it and
you you can add it to your library and
it will strengthen you uh in the Lord we
believe amen so thank you so very very
much Pastor and Pastor well done um this
is from Anan it is he he quotes that it
is sensitive and um so we're just going
to try to read through this very quickly
uh because it's it's rather lengthy and
we want to try to give it du due time I
am reaching out to you with a burning
question that's been bothering me for
quite some time here's my question I am
an elder in my local congregation and
there are a few members that are
struggling with homosexuality I know
that we have issues I know that we all
have issues we are struggling with and
do not claim to be better than anyone my
issue is that we try to help them
personally as well as inviting people
who have overcome this issue and they
refuse to listen according to church
policy these indiv individuals should
not hold membership in the church they
both seem to have membership in the
congregation and I seem to be the only
one bothered by it as a servant of the
Lord I feel as though I am a hypocrite
if I continue being an elder in the
church knowing that those biblical
principles are being uh disregarded by
my local church I pray I I prayed over
the matter however I would welcome more
Biblical advice as to how to move
forward we do not have a pastor and the
church is being led by three Elders of
which I am one sincerely looking forward
to your
response the first thing I want to say
in in addressing this I don't believe
believe you're being a hypocrite by
remaining in that church the reason I
say that is because the Church of God
needs Godly leaders in the church amen
sometimes being a leader is a lonely
advocation but it does not mean that you
should not stand for the Lord sometimes
it is going to be tough uh particularly
if you're standing instead of uh the
pastor so you're not being a hypocrite
and uh if you leave that church then the
church loses one witness that needs to
stand up for the Lord so my personal
counsel is to let your light shine where
God has put you bloom where you are
planted and don't be afraid to stand up
for the Lord now I've got some more
things to add I got a couple texts here
but I want to let the brethen weigh in
on this well the question that the
brother has is is is one of out of
concern and I appreciate that he's
concerned in the sense that the
leadership of the local church of he's
in it's been um affected by two
individuals who are taking a position of
leadership and he himself says in the in
his message that according to our church
policy well and which is actually based
on the Bible if we go to 1 Timothy 3 and
we actually read there what is the
office of the Elder of of what it's the
requirements uh in the word of God for
one who is an elder they're very clear
there you know the list is very precise
it says a bishop or an elder must be
blameless the husband of one wife
diligent so of good behavior given to
hospitality and opt to teach not given
to Wine Not Striker not greedy or a
filthy looker but patient not a browler
not Covetous one that rued well his own
house having his children in a
subjection with all gravity so this is
the requirements the characteristics of
a man who who is to be appointed for you
know to be an elder leader in the church
if these individuals are not fulfilling
these roles if the church has elected
three elders but they're actually
electing individuals who are
flawed I think that this is something
that should be taken to the church and
to reevaluate I mean right now maybe
it's too late it's already gone through
the year but you have to be very careful
that you don't elect individuals who
have this uh you know who are not
according to the Bible fit for
leadership otherwise you create yourself
or put yourself in a in a situation that
is very complicated as these individuals
more likely are not going to have give
sound counsel they're not going to be
able to lead the church correctly and in
the fear of God uh so I will suggest our
friend our Elder here that he uh remains
in his position as a true faithful
servant of the Lord and to um bring this
if it's possible to bring this attention
and if there's true you know if these
individuals are really you know uh if
they're struggling with something I I
don't think that makes necessarily them
the problem I think you to approach it
in a way where you actually realize that
they are not able to hold the office
because they are either struggling or
they're compromising their understanding
of the scriptures on this matter that's
where I would suggest the individual
takes this to the church board and and
to the church uh family because this is
something that the church family has to
see that's my advice there's a
difference between a tendency to
homosexuality and the practice of
homosexuality uh the question says uh
they are struggling with
homosexuality the question is are they
condoning it are they supporting it or
do they know it's wrong and they're
they're saying you know Holy Spirit help
me with this issue right now uh the
Elders of the church are to make sure
that the church conserves its Purity
amen doctrinal Purity yeah and personal
Purity yeah uh the Bible speaks clearly
against homosexuality the practice of
homosexuality not the tendency because
you know I have Tendencies too I just
have uh not to uh
yield to them yeah you know uh
Tendencies are not sin right Tendencies
are inclinations to sin but only when
you yield to the inclination does it
become sin right U and so uh I would say
that the Elders of the church need to
step to the plate and they need to be
kind yeah with these people not mean
Jesus loved the sinner he hated the sin
but he did not condone sin when you look
at the gospels MH and so um you know
love these people but at the same time
tell them because you love them that
you're going to follow the biblical
principle you're going to be kind to
them but you're going to follow the
biblical principle that you cannot have
church membership when you haven't
buried that particular sin because
baptism means burying your sins in the
water you know if you're going to say
well I'm going to continue practicing
this even after baptism
well then you're just you know your
baptism isn't really valid because
baptism means that you're willing to
forsake the sins that beset you before
yeah like you said we all have you know
Tendencies to many things but the the
problem is not a tendency if you
struggle with that and you're not acting
upon it or you're not yielding to that
Temptation you know it's okay but if
they're practicing as you mentioned
they're actually practicing this type of
habit or sinful ways then the church
needs to take matters and and you know
in that position of authority somebody
that is you know practicing a sin like
that must be in love must be you know U
helped correct that behavior and remov
from that office you know there are
certain sins because of the way they are
and because of our own inclinations we
find particularly difficult to deal with
but the truth is the wages of all sin is
death if you if you've got a
heterosexual
he's in the same boat right uh so uh we
we've got to show the same love and
respect and I think that the key as you
well in toned is practicing these he
says they are struggling and so we're
sort of parsing your language here but
struggling means they're they're they're
fighting a fight you know as long as
they're fighting a fight you've got to
fight with them there is no church that
is sinless every church has got some
problems and so if everybody left every
time he found a problem then we really
would be in trouble um I hope this this
helps you a little bit because we
certainly want you to be successful in
your leadership don't duck out stay in
and lift up Jesus again time is fif in
eternity as we say goodbye we wish you
God's blessings and his eternal peace
amen
[Music]